girls are failing to stretch their
brightest students by setting tests that
are too easy a report by the school's
regulator Ofsted says the Coalition has
made little progress in developing
academic high flyers that's from Joanna
Simpson hi I'm Owen I mean you're eight
and I'm a computer entrepreneur I want
to become a doctor when I'm older
this group is some of the brightest
young pupils at Drayton Manor High
School where they're continuing to reach
their full potential but England Schools
Inspectorate Ofsted says many like them
aren't being supported correctly this
school in London says regardless of her
pupils background they ought to be
respectful and have high aspirations
it's stretching me because my mind I can
feel expanding as I'm learning different
different subjects challenging the most
able in their first few years this head
teacher says is key to helping them
excel we try and make sure that our
students have this breadth of experience
and we teach valuable subjects the
things are really important employers
are looking for Drayton Manor High
School has been identified by Ofsted as
one of four best practice schools for
the way they stretch their most able
pupils but the Schools Inspectorate says
thousands of pupils across England's are
being let down as their schools don't
have such high expectations for what
they can achieve the survey found more
than a quarter of those who showed very
strong potential in English and maths
8:11 didn't achieve a grade B at GCSE as
their needs are not being prioritized
Ofsted is disappointed recommendations
it made two years ago is still not being
implemented as schools it says are being
complacent it's not just frustrating for
Ofsted it's frustrating for those young
people it's frustrating for their
parents and ultimately is frustrating
for the country because you know an
equal society and we will make a more
equal society if these children do as
well as they should he is stretching
students allows them to grasp knowledge
in the hope they may become the leading
minds of the future
Joanna Simpson Sky News